Sports Illustrated is actually
interesting because it is like the
hierarchy of what is acceptable in our
society right now there was four covers
there was the Kim Petrus you have Tran a
trans individual you have uh Martha
Stewarts you got an 81 year old lady
then you have Megan Fox she her whole
thing was talking about uh body
dysmorphia and then there was just
another lady named like Brooke Nader
Brooks Nader who I wonder if she's
related to Ralph Nader because that
would be very cool if that was true but
hers was just I won a beauty contest and
I was like why can't we talk about that
this lady like beat out 10 000 other
people to get this job because that
doesn't sell anymore because there is no
ESG funding in that story there is no
ideological way to Virtue signal to
people that you want to build your base
they're always looking to build this
Phantom audience the people who are
buying Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
editions don't care about Kim Petras at
least not if they're paying attention
and definitely don't care about seeing
Martha Stewart on the cover but there's
that's the hierarchy now you have to be
some type of oppressed group